I grew up poor and my dad was also
pretty cheap and because of that we
missed out on a lot of experiences and I
grew up man I'm bummed that I did this
but I grew up through my 20s and 30s
like if I saw a steak on the menu there
was $24.00 and I saw chicken that was 17
I'd be like even though I wanted this
day do you know what I mean like I
[ __ ] hate that my dad put that in my
head
so what I've started to do is listen
guys it's important not to be
willy-nilly with your [ __ ] money but
if you got a hundred bucks and it's
between 700 bucks and going to a concert
you've always want to see it go to that
[ __ ] concert
here's steel a year from now you're not
gonna have any idea or that hundred
dollars went but you'll remember the
concert so make some [ __ ] memories
while you can still make some memory so
taking that into account last September
I got to see six bands in one weekend
all on the bucket list
now I spent more than I should have on
this concert it was it was a it was old
cello was Coachella for old people that
anybody go did you don't have talked
about it was the stones the who
McCartney Neil Young Roger Waters and
Bob Dylan on the same weekend it was
amazing I think we didn't hear ever seen
Bob Dylan report yeah he eats a bag of
dicks that [ __ ] he's so bad did
he play any hits when you saw no [ __ ]
attack dude doesn't play warhead are you
kidding me and I was so mad at like
playing with a blue and the guy next to
me was like yeah well the Bob Dylan he's
earned the right to play what he wants
and I would agree with you if he's
playing in his own [ __ ] living room
but he wasn't
there were 90,000 people there who paid
a lot of [ __ ] money paint tangles up
and blue you piece of beef jerky [ __ ]
you
I will fight Bob Dylan right now I'll
tell you that right now I'll fight that
[ __ ] I think I got a shot about
Dylan
I'd like to hit him once just to hear
him go I just but on the way in right I
told my brothers I'm like hey guys I'm
taking mushrooms this weekend and they
were like which night I said you hear me
this weekend and they were like why you
gotta go you think oh you're gonna do
that by yourself and I said no they give
me 90,000 people there and they were
like you know but you don't know any of
them I was like well I'm I'm gonna now
okay so in by the way I did it out of
respect for the bands we were going to
see I felt like they would want me to be
[ __ ] up right so rich got a curiosity
round of applause and I'm assuming this
will be larger round of applause and in
most cities people who have taken
mushrooms before okay I was in
Huntsville Alabama last week and I asked
that question and one dude goes I got
some on my salad right now
[Laughter]
and what I'm talking about
so after dealing I was like I'm taking
the mushrooms now I'm not I'm not I'm
not putting myself through another
disappointing show
now following Dylan was the stones and I
had never seen the stones before and so
I am by the way city next to me was this
old Hispanic couple and the dude had
those like the round tiny glasses and he
had a tiny ponytail you know one of
these and it was pulled tight so dude
look surprised the whole show and she
scratched his back the entire concert
Shh two and a half hours so about five
minutes before the music starts I get my
first little warm hug and I'm like I'm
like this is about to be the best night
of my [ __ ] luck right and so the guy
next to me he turns to me to go hey man
and I go hey and he goes what's your
name I said Josh and he said who do you
think the best rock band of all time is
Josh hey listen guys I'm about to trip
balls right
[Music]
so the last thing I want to do is have a
conversation with the Mexican John
Lennon do you know what I mean like I'm
on Pasadena on that right [ __ ] now
right so I just tell him what I think
it's gonna answer the stop most
conversation I said the Beatles and he
goes wrong man it's stones she and I
have seen the stone sixty-six times she
said yeah and weary fall in love every
show and I was like yeah I was like
you're not sweet and I said very cool
for me to watch the stones for the first
time next to people who've seen them
sixty-six times and I'm gonna watch them
Reve fall in love right in front of my
face
that's the belt that melt off my [ __ ]
skull you know
[Music]
I felt like telling them I hope you
don't mind watching this concert next to
the Ghost Rider because I'm not for sure
what's gonna happen from here on out
hi I'm Dean n started 10th dananddana
and I'm like oh my god right I couldn't
believe what was happening not kidding
ten minutes in dude turns to me and he
goes hey man and I go ahead and he goes
what's your name and I was like
[Music]
I said Josh and he goes who do you think
the best rock-and-roll band of all time
is just and for a second I thought oh my
god these mushrooms are amazing I was
like this is the most visceral deja vu
I've ever had in my entire life and
obviously I'm gonna lie to you for a
second I thought I can see the [ __ ]
future
I know how this conversation ends oh I'm
gonna see this concert twice when we did
the whole thing 66 times reef fall in
love not kidding no joke
12 minutes later dude turns to me he
goes hey man and I go don't you asking
that [ __ ] question again dude and his
wife goes to me you'll have to excuse
him shhh he's done a lot of drugs he
doesn't have any short-term memory and I
was like well no wonder you got to see
the stone 66 [ __ ] times and just so
you know you don't reef all in love he
thinks he bangs some chick at the Stones
concert every weekend
not as romantic as you think it is ma'am
I'm just saying
and then I will tell you what the true
privilege of my life being there that
weekend was watching a generation of
people watch their idols for the last
time guys so cool to see so cool to see
because they were partying without
inhibition look if we saw a bar full of
65 year old people upstairs getting
[ __ ] up you'd be like go home
yeah so you'd make a group decision like
hey all of you you need to go right but
this concert was for them it was for
them to come and relive a snapshot of
their life so they partied without
inhibition and it was amazing to see and
because of that there was a lot of old
white guy dance circles popping up all
over the place if you haven't seen one
of those
and when I say dance circle there was a
lot of to gun salutes you know like and
you can tell when they like the song you
know why the guns went over the air
there was one guy near me doing a lot of
pencil and then near me also there was a
big guy doing kicks like this he had
been gone to 40 big dude he's kick and
he's like yeah and I was like look at
the big guy go like he's killing it and
then big guy just collapses and I was
like oh no he [ __ ] Riverdance himself
to death like and he's not moving and
I'm like oh this dude is it [ __ ]
trouble right so they would come in EMTs
come they put him a stretcher wheel
amount you know and he's saying his eyes
are closed and one of his friends
there's near me leans over and goes dude
has to be like mid-60s or something
he goes hey man you gonna be okay
and the guy just opens his eyes and he
goes yeah I'm just really tired
and his friend said what he goes yeah I
got tired from dancing around so I laid
down on the ground and then the EMT said
you I can't lay here and I told them I'm
not [ __ ] getting up I'm too tired and
the EMT said if you don't get up sir
we're gonna have to wheel you out of
here and I said that actually sounds
kind of nice shake it a little weird
there was about 280 290 pounds dude run
around shirtless doing this to be and
I'm watching him and I'm like boy I
really hope he doesn't come over here
you know like so he comes over and his
belly's all sweaty so there's like
tracers flying off his stomach and his
whole stomachs moving all at once and
I'm like I'm never looking away I knew I
was gonna get [ __ ] trapped in that
thing right and then he said something
to me that I promise you has never been
uttered before in the history of human
beings he shakes his belly at me and he
looks at me he goes hey I go what's up
he goes
how many knuckles deep you think he can
go on my bellybutton
he goes how many Knuckles deep I go none
nut nut roast beef dinner michael steep
and he goes why not I was like why why
would I
and he goes everybody's doing that they
go who is doing that and he goes
everybody now look guys I'm shrooming
you know what I mean and I don't want to
be the only guy who doesn't figure [ __ ]
this to the bellybutton I don't want to
be debbie downer you know part of the
group
so I go oh oh what finger should I use
[Music]
because I'd use the index ok guys way to
get so much worse
so I go to Luba my finger and he goes
now you won't need Lube in it just
[ __ ] with rooms man right and I look
at him I go we got room to spare big
fella and he goes ok and I go to pull my
finger out and you know when you put
your finger in one of those Chinese
finger locks and for whatever reason
when you try to pull it out and clamps
down on it
I couldn't get my finger out of his
[ __ ] bellybutton
I would fool home on this dude's stomach
like cuz there's no way I'm going out
like that right and it just popped out
right as soon as it pops out he looks at
me he goes we finally found somebody
[Applause]
I thought everybody was doing that he
goes who would do that
[Applause]
now let's get into a little truth time
you ready for a little truth truth truth
time as a man as a man as a man I had to
fight every fiber in my body not to
smell that finger one [ __ ] time
don't you me you hypocritical
[ __ ] you raised your nuts the
first thing you do is smell oh you've
got a unicorn on your finger you're
never gonna smell that [ __ ] again now
listen I did it I did it I did it didn't
I I did not do it I did not do it I did
it and then I gave my brother a dirty
sanchez and I was like dude put a desk
felt like he walked around the whole day
like this
[Music]
because that's the type of [ __ ] life
[Music]
[Music]